adaptation to climate change cancer
protecting ocean and waters climate
neutral and smart cities healthy soils
these are some of our main challenges
and opportunities these are our european
missions
eu missions they're about what we can do
together
to tackle big challenges
in health
in climate
and the environment to shape the future
that we want to live in missions have
ambitious goals and will deliver
concrete results by 2030. part of the
horizon europe missions are rooted in
research and innovation
but that is only the beginning of the
process
eu missions
they bring researchers
innovators
businesses policymakers
and citizens
together and provide them with the tools
and the funding that they need
eu missions put people at the heart of
eu policy making whether you are active
in your region in your city or in your
neighborhood
we need your help to make it work
missions are part of a bigger european
vision they go hand in hand with the
european green deal the new european
bauhaus
a europe fix for the digital age
the europe's beating cancer plan
european union's long-term vision for
rural areas by 2030 we aim to restore
our ocean and waters improve the lives
of more than 3 million people affected
by cancer
make 150 regions and communities climate
resilient achieve 100 climate neutral
and smart cities create 100 living clubs
and lighthouses to lead the transition
towards healthy soils
this is our mission
join us
you